started working as a sales professional
after completing my graduation in 2021
but business analytics attracted me more
I wanted to change my domain for that I
needed skills and a professional
certification simply love helped me
achieve my goals currently I am working
as a business analyst with a hundred
percent salary help hey my name is
I am a business analyst at code hash
within my organization I tried to close
the gap between technological solutions
and Commercial Goods I started my career
as a sales professional but I realized
that the field of business analysis fits
me better so I started looking for an
online course that would help me Excel
as a business analysis simply learn
offered me everything I was looking for
I enrolled in simply learns business
analyst master's program
the course is specially designed for
working professionals they offer
flexibility to Learners to learn at
their own pace even before completing
the course I started working as a
business analyst at Tech gym
after the course completion I received a
job offer from old hash as a business
analyst they offered me 100 increment in
myself I feel delighted in upcoming
years I want to be a business architect
in the IIT domain I'm actually selling
in my current profile thanks to the
course
in my free time I love listening to
music and playing football
choosing simply learn to upgrade myself
was a right this year